[Musique]
en décembre comme partout dans l'île si
la hausse est en fleurs l'occasion
idéale pour faire classe dans la forêt
ouais comme ce qu'on va faire cette
année au quai est ce que c'est la seule
chose qu'on a fait ensemble l'année
dernière parce qu'on l'a fait deux on a
planté des arbres
quelles qualités d'art déjà endémique
l'académie de la réunion mascarin jardin
botanique et enfin le conservatoire
botanique national de mascarin se sont
associés pour développer ce projet
citoyen pour planter dans la ville
on a pour objectif de proposer un projet
avec une rigueur scientifique
l'idée c'est d'installer des espèces
indigènes et endémiques dans la commune
sous la forme d'un massif ornementale de
ce fait faut pas se tromper quelles sont
les espèces qu'on va planter quelles
sont les espèces qui sont
caractéristiques du site du site du
cirque de cilaos et comment partager ce
message avec la population si la hausse
avec les jeunes pour ce projet là les
jeunes seront ambassadeurs les enfants
je vous présente les scientifiques
botanistes du conservatoire botanique de
mascarin dès les premiers pas la
recherche des graines des 1700 espèces
indigènes de la forêt réunionnaise
devient une aventure une démarche
scientifique qui permet d'apprendre et
surtout de savoir être dans le milieu
forestier inchangé corse qui est en
train 5 et à l'air un petit peu
maigrelet voilà et vous voyez les fruits
qui sont au bout des branches
ça c'est de changer corse il est
beaucoup plus grand si vous voyez les
fruits comme ça si tu cherches il a
trouvé la guerre qu'est-ce que ça que ça
sert de sa mort sont sédentaires et de
la forêt benjoin dû connaître racines et
de croiser un bois de boîtes aux
libanais connaîtra c'est quoi et on peut
dire que c'est un savoir être et savoir
être et savoir reconnaître et je pense
que le contact qu'on peut avoir avec une
forêt c'est aussi quelque chose qui
apporte au delà d'un simple bonheur de
voir ou autre c'est aussi là on est par
exemple à cilaos les forêts
qui bordent la ville de silos sont des
forêts extrêmement riche tous ces étages
de végétation sont scrutés un
référencement qui permettra également
aux enseignants de créer des outils
pédagogiques pour les usagers de demain
[Musique]